today you are in for a treat because we
are going to perform brain to audio yes
listen to music straight from your brain
kind of and more yes I hear you asking
doctor how is this even possible well
this new paper showcases an EEG based
technique to perform the science
fiction-like experiment normally EEG
electroencephalography means that we
place electrodes on the scalp and then
we listen to the brain from the outside
and by that I mean looking at the
electric activity however here this work
uses intracranial EEG that requires
electrodes to be on the surface of the
brain thus making it an invasive
technique that makes scientists able to
listen to the brain straight from its
surface so what can we do with that and
the answer is absolutely miraculous
things Le let's look at the experiment
design and see what happened first a
song is played to 29 patients this was
Another Brick in the Wall the classic
from Pink Floyd then an auditory
spectrogram is Created from this song
this enables us to look at the song and
understand a little better where we are
and what is happening then scientists
recorded the neural activity of the
brain at the point where the electrodes
were placed and created a spectrogram
from information that was obtained from
the brain this is a decoding step and
the one in this particular diagram was
done by a neural network decoding real
neural information by using a digital
neural network what a time to be alive
now hold on to your papers because we
are going to look at the two
spectrograms and oh my goodness the
information that was read from the brain
indeed refers to the same song no
question about it due to copyright
constraints I can't play it here but you
can listen to it through the link in the
video description and I have to say that
of course it is not Hi-Fi quality but if
you know the song you can tell what is
being played in the brain and even
seeing the lyrics to it absolutely
incredible the paper also showcases a
ton of little golden nuggets of
information I love this chart that tells
us exactly how the quality of the
Reconstruction increases with the number
of electrodes little measurement points
being used on the brain adding more of
these typically increases the resolution
of the information we get but also
increases the noise as well so here a
proper way of decoding helps a great
deal this paper is an inch interesting
Showcase of what is possible through the
power of research and since this data
has to be read from the surface of your
brain I would not worry about anyone
eavesdropping on which scholarly paper
you are thinking about for instance a
couple hundred episodes ago we talked
about an absolutely amazing paper that
allowed brain to text transcription it
took patients who had a paralyzed hand
and got this all the test subjects have
to do is Imagine writing the letters and
they magically appeared on the screen
and now hold on to your papers fellow
Scholars and just look at how quickly it
goes 90 characters per minute with over
94 percent of accuracy which can be
improved to over 99 of accuracy with an
additional autocorrect technique that is
absolutely amazing we can learn a ton
from these papers for instance in the
that one we learned that it is quite
remarkable that even years after
paralysis the motor cortex is still
strong enough to be able to be read by a
brain computer interface well enough for
such typing speed and accuracy it truly
feels like we are living in a science
fiction World Imagine how many people
around the world we could have with this
so today brain to text is possible and
brain to audio is also possible but here
comes the best part for people who are
unable to communicate with us through
speech now they can not only write to us
but with this new paper we can even
reconstruct the musicality of their
speech as well straight from the brain
imagine if we could have heard the late
Stephen Hawking talk like that how
amazing would that have been wow if you
are looking for inexpensive Cloud gpus
for AI Lambda now offers the best prices
in the world for GPU Cloud compute no
commitment or negotiation required just
sign up and launch an instance and hold
on to your papers because with the
Lambda GPU Cloud you can now get on
demand h100 instances for just 199 per
hour yes 199 and they are one of the
first Cloud providers to offer publicly
available on-demand h100 XS did I
mention they also offer persistent
storage so join researchers at
organizations like apple MIT and Caltech
in using Lambda Cloud instances
workstations or servers make sure to go
to lambdalabs.com papers to sign up for
one of their amazing GPU instances today
thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time